well I think one of the one of the
scenarios is the one regarding what our
press release was about concerning t pyx
it is but I think that most scenarios
now for example trying to account for
the mass extinctions that have occurred
throughout geological history that the
for example a gamma-ray burst a burst of
gamma rays from a very massive star that
collapses in on itself with the prompt
formation of a black hole and then with
with gamma ray jets that if they're
oriented just right the the gamma ray
bursts will be directed at earth these
could be potentially devastating the
gamma ray bursts in addition to that
there is a lot of debris in our solar
system that was part of the fundamental
building blocks of the solar system a
primordial matter we call it pristine
chemical composition there's been no
chemical alteration the comets are good
examples of that and some of the
asteroids are very primitive that is
they they have a composition that is
very christine and primordial it hasn't
been altered by geological evolution
that is they haven't been incorporated
in large bodies that undergo geological
evolution so these are the basic
building blocks well these building
blocks are that they're out there and
and of course they can potentially
collide with the planets including earth
and in fact this is how we think the
moon originated the most widely held
theory for the origin of the moon is the
giant impactor theory where billions of
years ago after earth had had developed
an iron core after headed we call it
differentiation where the heavy elements
sink to the center of a newly-formed
planet the lighter elements float to the
surface because they're different
density that earth once it
differentiated early in the history of
the solar system when they were
collisions with other bodies was more
frequent earth was struck by a
mars-sized intruder body that then
we'll find a large portion of Earth's
mantle at the collision site and ejected
this liquid rock out into space this
liquid rock then cooled and solidified
and then reassembled itself by gravity
and that's what we have now according to
this theory as the present-day moon it
eventually and then suffered other
collisions the moon suffered other
collisions that gives the man of the
moon appearance the lunar seas for
example those blue patches are actually
gigantic impact basins that have been
flooded with lava with liquid rock
during lunar volcanism during during
volcanic activity in lunar history so
these collisions happen much more
frequently in the past but that doesn't
rule out that they can't happen now so I
think it's an area that is really
deserving a lot of exploration as is
being done now
well within the human lifespan it's it's
a very very low probability but on the
other hand one cannot rule it out there
are three families of asteroids that
actually have the potential of clotting
with earthy Liam or asteroids the Apollo
asteroids and the Aten asteroids the
Apollo asteroids actually have orbits
that are internal to Earth's orbit and
the there perhaps the most likely the
Apollo asteroids and those are being
monitored very carefully bye-bye
telescopic patrols patrol observatories
that have been set up and and if one of
these Apollo asteroids were to enter
into collision course with earth
hopefully we'd have enough warning but
we do in fact have the technology now
and in the future to intercept and
possibly deflect such a body but during
the span of a human lifetime it's it's
not it's not likely it's rather
improbable it's something large enough
to do a great deal of devastation of the
globe what would happen now there was an
event in 1908 the Tunguska event that it
appears to be a porous primitive
asteroid that detonated that exploded
above the ground and this level an
entire forest in Central Siberia in
visca river but fortunately the area was
very sparsely populated and there were
no recorded human fatalities but if that
event had happened a few hours before in
other words if it had happened when when
if the detonation happened over the
ocean that could have generated a tidal
waves tsunamis and that could have had a
devastating effect on the coastlines so
it was really a lucky thing that the
Tunguska event occurred over Central
Siberia and not over a populated area
like it for example in Central and
Western Europe
that we our leadership would would meet
with NASA officials and and plan to
intercept such a body with with a either
a kinetic energy device a missile that
would ram into it but they would have to
be very careful because you don't want
to fragment it too much you don't want
to fragment it in such a way that the
fragments themselves would would enhance
the devastation so you want to make sure
it has to be carefully calculated but I
think this kind of a scenario has been
anticipated and I think that both with
our space program with other space
programs that the Russian space program
the Chinese I think there are plans for
in case of such an event I mean and of
course you would want to avoid worldwide
panic and that kind of thing so it's
it's I think the details remain to be
seen but such plans have been in the
works and in case of for example an
apollo asteroid being perturbed into a
collision with us with earth